[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au Havre le Paque beau France est entré
en cale sèche pour subir une petite
opération qui doit en faire le plus
stable des transatlantiques à la place
des deux hélices latérales à PES il sera
doté de deux nouvelles hélices à 5 PES
énormees fleurs d'acier de 27 tonnes
[Musique]
chacune désormais le navire aura ses
quatre hélices identiques ce qui lui
conférera une plus grande
[Musique]
souplesse sans doute les promeneurs des
jardins des Tuileries n'ont-ils jamais
prêté qu'une attention légère aux
statues qui bordent les allées
personne ne regrettera qu'on leur
substitue des sculptures de
Maillol pour avoir une première idée de
ce qu'apportera cette substitution les
maquettes de 16 des plus belles œuvres
du grand artiste disparu ont été disposé
dans les jardins demain les originaux
prendront leur place et selon le vœ de
Monsieur André mer les Tuileries
deviendront le premier musée de
sculpture en plein
[Applaudissements]
air TR ny au détour d'une pelouse
n'est-ce pas un beau cadeau fait à
Paris c'est ce même Paris qui vient
d'être le théâtre d'un drame aussi
incompréhensible qu'inexcusable
boulevard Le Fèvre la carcasse de fer et
de béton d'un immeuble de 12 étage en
construction s'est effondré sans raison
apparente ensevelissant les ouvriers qui
travaillaient jour et nuit les équipes
de secours se sont succédé on a
jusqu'ici retrouvé 23 cadavres on compte
également 17 blessés graves et quelques
blessés légers aucun espoir ne subsiste
de découvrir d'autres survivants il faut
que toute la lumière soit fait sur les
causes de cette catastrophe et que si
les besoins justice soit
[Musique]
faite une crise extrêmement grave oppose
l'état de Panama aux États-Unis gardien
et locataire de la zone du canal des
deux océans il a suffit d'un incident
pour mettre le feu au poudre et faire
éclater la tension l'attente entretenue
par le désir panaméen de voir Modifier
le traité de 1903 qui fait du canal un
monopole américain la population s'est
soudain révolté contre les détails
irritants d'une occupation consacré sans
doute par des traités mais qui tient mal
compte des intérêts
[Musique]
panaméens des manifestations se sont
déroulées en divers points de la zone du
canal des cous ont été échangé et le
sang a coulé
une trentaine de morts du côté panaméen
qu du côté américain ont rendu la crise
[Musique]
inéluctable et les Obs des victimes ont
marqué la profondeur du drame
l'unanimité du peuple a approuvé la
rupture des relations diplomatiques avec
les États-Unis et le problème est
d'autant moins facile à résoudre que
l'approche des élections dans les deux
pays ne peut que durcir les positions
c'est de façon tout à fait impontue que
le leader cubain FID Castro a rendu à
monsieurchov une nouvelle visite à
Moscou en dpit des communiqués qui
semble indiquer que ce voyage est motivé
par des raisons de repos et de loisirs
on est facilement amené à penser que la
visite de Castro pourrait être liée à la
crise de Panama dans laquelle les
États-Unis ont déjà dénoncé les
influences
castristes
une révolution vient de bouleverser le
toutjeune état de Zanzibar qui n'accéda
à l'indépendance que le 10 décembre
dernier un ex-policier originaire du
Kenya John Okello a renversé le
gouvernement s'est proclamé maréchal et
a pris le pouvoir au nom de l'opposition
africaine le sultan ayant réussi à fuir
les quelques 50000 Arabes qui tenaient
les leviers de commande tant politique
qu'économique et les 20000 Indiens qui
formaient fraction commerçante ont été
les victimes de l'opération on les a
rassemblé dans des camps mais on parle
aussi de plusieurs milliers de
morts le spectacle des hôpitaux de
fortune où les services de santé sont
restés sur place malgré l'évacuation des
Anglais démontre le caractère sanglant
de cette révolution c'est ainsi que
l'île de la girofle est devenue la
république populaire de
zanziba Auer le siège de la Ligue arabe
a servi de cadre à ce que l'on a appelé
la conférence au sommet du monde arabe
sur l'invitation du président Gamal
Abdel Nasser le roi Husain de Jordanie
le président Ben Bella le président
bourgiba le roi Hassan 2 du Maroc et les
chefs d'État où les représentants des h
autres pays arabes se sont réunis pour
étudier en commun le moyen de s'opposer
au captage des eaux du Jourdain par
[Musique]
Israël la France et le canadaont
organiser des consultations politiques
régulières ainsi en on décidé le général
de Gaulle et le Premier ministre
canadien monsieur Lester peerson venu
lui rendre une visite officielle une
soirée de gala à l'Élysée a marqué ce
voyage dont l'importance tant à l'égard
des relations franco-américaine que de
l'avenir de la communauté Atlantique ne
peut être
discuté il se peut d'ailleurs que de son
côté le général de Gaul se rend bientôt
au
Canada
[Musique]
de jeunes Français vont coopérer à la
promotion des populations africaines
monsieur Triboulet ministre délégué
chargé de la Coopération a présenté au
Premier ministre monsieur George
Pompidou le premier groupe des
volontaires du progrès 13 jeunes gens
qui ont décidé de mettre durant 2 ans
leurs compéten professionnell au service
de la modernisation rurale d'une nation
d'Afrique
francophone
rappelez que la colonne vertébrale et
l'axe de soutien essentiel du corps est
bien sûr un lieu commun mais sans doute
n penseon jamais assez pendant toute la
vie en effet la colonne vertébrale est
mise à rue d'épreuve les gestes les plus
simples et les plus quotidiens la
malmènent et requierrent d'elle des
qualités de solidité de résistance et de
souplesse assez évidentes pour qu'on la
prépare de bon heur aux nécessités de
notre vie
turbulente
on ne surveille jamais trop les
mauvaises tenues des écoliers au travail
parfois dû à un éclairage malorienté
ou ces attitudes si souvent observé de
ces enfants assis sur le bout de leur
chaise et qui prennent avant l'âge un
air
voûté que dire de ces cartables
surchargés à plaisir qui deviennent à la
longue des causes de déviation alors
qu'il suffit d'équiper les enfants de
cartabl à Bretel ou de les obliger à
réduire le contenu au strict
minimum plutôt que de risquer en arriver
à de véritables déformations qui une
fois acquise demande un traitement très
long et très pénible il importe de
prévenir le mal à sa source une
musculature trop faible prédispose
l'enfant pendant toute sa croissance à
des déviations susceptibles de devenir
des déformations des exercices
correctifs appropriés sont alors
nécessaires pour aider à combattre les
mauvaises
attitudes dans ce domaine la natation
dirigé possède le maximum de valeur
thérapeutique dans la mesure où elle
étire la colonne vertébrale et renforce
la sangle musculaire qui tient l'édifice
du Tron la vie d'adulte réclame une
constitution solide il suffit en
définitif de bien petite servitude et
d'un peu de persévérance pour y préparer
les
enfants à Grenoble les Allemands de
l'Ouest Marik Kilius et hansan Baumler
qui sont depuis de nombreuses années
déjà les enfants chéris de la gloire ont
enlevé sans difficulté le titre de
champion d'Europe de leur spécialité ils
sont inimitables aucun couple de
patineur n'atteint une telle
perfection mais car il y a un mai Marik
et sont au bord du divorce en tout bien
tout honneur puisquils ne sont pas
mariés on leur offre millions par an
pour passer professionnel dit oui mais
Mar a dit non elle préfère le mariage à
l'argent résultat leur association va
bientôt prendre
[Musique]
fin va décevoir tous ses admirateurs
dans un an on ne le reverra plus sur une
patinoire il a l'intention en effet de
troquer ses patins à glace contre la
blouse blanche du médecin alors
regardons-le et admirons pour l'une des
dernières fois l'un des plus grands
patineurs de tous les
[Musique]
temps
et avant sa retraite Alain calma
pourrait bien ajouter à son titre de
champion d'Europe la médaille d'or des
Jeux
[Musique]
Olympiques y